what is up everybody how's it going I
hope you're having a great morning so
far or afternoon actually it is past
12:00 here I finally got everything
working what's the update I was
struggling you guys already know how it
is it's I don't know why there's always
an issue with me I'm sorry but we're
here we made it we're playing some apex
legends right now we've got Tony and
Eric in the party also and there is
actually a lot of pretty big changes in
terms of nerfs and buffs with other
characters and and Lobos out brand new
so I'm gonna give her a shot I ran
around in firing range for like 30
seconds I was hoping to get more
practice Simon but I was dealing with
the update it's fine
right here I'm gonna get carried right
now right Eric and Tony is gonna be a
great time they're also in discard of me
right now so I did I also did 30 seconds
in the firings in the training zone or
whatever the firing range before it got
here
I got to see mirages new alts which is
like super cool I'm gonna do um I guess
yeah I'll start off with Mirage but we
got a definitely get revenant in the mix
here too when we start going cuz I think
that they have new like incidental
dialogue going on or something like that
and so I think they like the revenant
loba dynamic yeah is gonna be super cool
let's Jays got the cool eagle on a
member the name of that Egyptian god
Osiris oh snap and yes there was map
changes to you guys look at that skull
town is no more it got body literally
it's gone I mean I know that was like
Eric's favorite place but I could not
survive there
it was a real fun hot zone it all right
I'll go rev this one that's weird it
wouldn't let me pick him now whatever
okay
sorry we got it covered really I didn't
even select her yet so I was like what
is it's because I ever been why it
wouldn't let me pick her either
wait no I literally mouse over I don't
know that's weird
no I'm super high it is weird having
let's warm up round guys
that's so weird all right well we get to
show off the new system Mirage she's
just already bamboozling everyone right
now all right let's go spicy that's
crazy
I'm good straight down and half finder
get nerfed his grappling hook no it just
takes longer than or something there's
yeah there's a lot of tunnel a cool-down
changes and stuff that happens I
definitely did not today I'm gonna grab
your banner at least maybe good luck I
got it you got a Spitfire ahead
here's fun okay I am I do not play
Bangalore at all so at least I got my
double time ow
hmm getting a little bit of lag on my
end too but maybe I should turn down
some of these oh you're down to alright
well this is gonna be fun
you got this Garver this thing working
I have never messed with these settings
ever alright there we go alright so
someone in the chat says a little bit it
might be broken right now for thinking
we're picking so we just might get who
we want we are definitely trying to play
low this Lobos so what happens we went
in we select characters but it didn't
give us the characters that we selected
so let's do um what if we uh in the
lobby like choose art defaults and maybe
that'll work oh that is what you did
yeah
oh okay I can't click wait wait wait
wait wait I don't want to do that I
can't even switch the legend yeah no me
neither
alright stuff going on I would show up
some of the battle path stuff also oh
there we go okay I can click it now
interesting it just popped up I'm so
here's Loba I'm gonna show off some of
her skins right now I actually this is
one of her like blue ones that I bought
earlier cuz I love flowers I thought it
looked really good
but her gold standard one is so gorgeous
I love it her pigtails are adorable
I like this whole color palette but
there's also one in red which is also
really good and then Purple Rain she's
kind of like these little axes on her
back the tattoos it's really cool and
then one also in red and black so we've
got revenant and we've got Lobo so who's
the next overwatch character they're
gonna do you think okay so let's see if
we can show off some of this battle pass
stuff click so they have a new tab and
everything for all of this stuff now so
if you saw I went to the store and or
even from this page it has its own tab
right at the top got the battle pass
fresh I'm fresh right now level one
because I just got it there's some good
stuff at level one though there was a
couple skins that I liked yeah this is
the wraith silver specter
and then rabbin and got a skin blood
Holmes got one so I guess you know the
theme is gold right so everyone is it's
got some gold touches in there oh yeah
so Mirage has the Fool's Gold legendary
skin which looks really cool I like all
these little details it's a little
scroll okay let's see if the game is
calmed down and it lets us pick our
characters let's do it we'll see my my
currency and the top right is just like
a bouncing white line I don't know if
yours is doing that but I actually will
sort itself out minded but it was doing
that my friends is doing that too Jordan
was saying he was having problems on
Xbox too so it's like all across I think
you said already purchase but yeah like
this this update is like minutes fresh
or like an hour's rush like we yes
seriously we just jumped in right now
okay alright to not select it
indefinitely
hungry you don't have low but Lauren I
have give you gotta find which character
will give us loba just start mashing
everyone okay what I did who'd you pick
originally I think I clicked well I
don't I typically don't click until like
it's my turn I know you can but I I was
hovering over Rev interesting Mirage is
bamboozling all of us yeah let's see if
we can uh I wonder if alright were you
where we drop in at least we've got Lobo
we can we bring some fun loot I'll try
to stay next to you so everyone can see
yeah that's good faster
I gotta get your maps or I do too
actually the treasure map oh yeah
there's a lot of extra side missions and
stuff now maybe by the end of the stream
we'll work out a formula and figure out
how to actually get the character we
want we'll just keep it yeah so maybe if
you I don't know we'll try to recreate
what you did if you like harbor okay oh
I see oh yeah yeah yeah everyone there's
meter way ahead all right I'm gonna okay
where did I move to you bracelet oh
there's definitely someone on me whoa
that bracelet has arc Oh No okay wait
hold on he's ready that bracelet slides
man tell you what armor coming at you
Persia okay I downed one but there's
like someone's sniping oh wait oh yeah
so the Mastiff is now a weapon that [ __ ]
everywhere here they nurse the little
one I have one already
oh yeah take it
no I accidentally picked up the light
army take that thank you no use at our
station oh yeah yeah oh I wasn't on it
we missed it let's do it everyone who's
standing on this platform will get oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it actually
happened pretty fast so strip which was
interesting I thought it was gonna be
like longer fighting oh yeah
they just don't oh the domed got nerfed
a little bit see right it's not up this
long or something like a shorter yeah a
couple seconds I'm stuck
going in okay everyone in it all right
yeah I'm in it others they're right up
here with me oh no no um okay
there was a knock team all right try
again
it's all right warmup rounds guys
they're all warm-up rounds until we live
on that's how this exactly all right
this time I'm just gonna hover over
mirage and see if maybe yeah like
instead of actually selecting that
bracelet is super cool though let me
tell you what that thing it had like I I
was throwing that thing like it felt
like a football field distance okay I'm
like so um Lopes not free unless you
have like points already stacked up like
in-game currency I just so happen to
have enough in-game currency to buy her
but you can also get your next coin
skitter
yeah apex coins are the real money
currency and then there's also the
in-game I don't remember what they call
the the in Game one but okay I'm just
gonna hover over mirage and not click
anything okay let's see what happens oh
is it gonna work now or am i game
jebaited
oh it worked alright okay so let me
whenever I pick actually don't have
caustic oh no what
Pathfinder's swung in but lifeline
showed up on that's a real bamboozle
okay that might have been because I'm
selected her last second I don't know
maybe maybe it might have sent me to
Lobo because that's who you know what I
bet hovering over still sent me to my
default which was Lobo right so okay
we'll try that I'll try to actually
click on Mirage alright so yeah let's go
back over there that was pretty fun and
maybe some people would be distracted by
the shiny stuff and be able to hang it
yeah I got shiny I got the shiny vision
alright we will figure out a way to get
lava
[Music]
but yeah there's also a ton of new it's
lines are slide yeah everyone dies cool
man would be an optimist oh there's a
ton of purple in that building though
that I just flew by crabs oh there's a
ton of purple over here and I'm lifeline
okay gosh yeah
so let me not accidentally throw out my
button all right they're all over here
in that building okay yeah oh nice I
gotta show you back - I'm moving toward
you guys and they're gonna be on my tail
um I kind of have some stuff to fight
now so should be okay yeah III do have
done there's something purple up there
in that chest
yep oh I'm gonna die no no no okay
there's a life plane right here and uh
yeah lobe is here
nice Watson's women your white say she's
won the life's one
yeah there's two there's two here we're
both down over a ball gown all right
that did not go very smoothly for me but
it's fun I could have sari picked up
another gun but I only had one my match
summary does not load all right so I'm
going to sew the tabs yeah can't change
my default right now but I will the
default it will change based on who you
just played as though okay I'm gonna
select Ironman I'm gonna go for a mirage
this time and then I'm not even gonna
select it I'm just gonna let it run that
it's time to run out so a point of order
for anyone looking to play lobha
definitely the bracelet seems to be good
for sneaking up on people but if you're
trying to like straight up drop into the
fight there's like enough time of you
warping over there that they'll just get
the drop on ya
yeah let's go Brandon welcome back you
said Eric T exactly who's here we
dragged him along alright um Mirage for
me okay okay
okay let's see if it changes I'm gonna
select urban because you guys selected
right okay all right let's go now Jess
cast um this I don't think I serve a
survivor but for a moment there is just
some really weird things going on in
character select but it seems to have
worked itself out and yeah I'm gonna
give loba a try first game with her
finally sorry guys now you'll finally
see her on on screen I know okay the the
new Mirage stuff is super cool though I
was playing around with that a little
bit in the firing range
it's like controlling the decoy super
cool I want to see it in action I want
to see a solo so let's try to gets one
of those combination things it reminds
me of you know that the double cherry in
Mario 3d World
yeah well you make like oh it's like
it's it's literally like just multiple
identical copies doing the same action
weight version where we dropping okay
same spot
yeah it's really cool the way it works
like I think you could really you could
definitely like beat people with it for
sure like even more than before
at least one squad at least him
we're gonna hit for land first maybe we
want to hit this T building you wanna go
here oh I see you Lulu
that's interesting yeah and that cool
man Oh No
thank you that was just for fun
I think somebody around us though okay
yeah on the lower level there's at least
one there okay oh did they just use that
power
oh they used all yeah they killed their
her black market so I'm Ken yeah we can
actually oh I found the other one Oh
what is that
Jason the other one he used Casa cult
because he uh oh it looks weird
Oh No hold on no I was like I could land
this shop oh thanks
oh I had was a massive that was not good
for any range site thank you oh cool
yeah I had my own - I guess I was close
enough alt should have everything in the
vicinity that's cool box layout is
different - really let me see yeah I
can't take yeah it's all grayed out
though Oh interesting it's just like
stuck well the stuff I just took was off
her body so if you saw it disappear from
the black mark is because I took it from
her party oh no I can do it yeah I'm in
it right now you can only take two items
I think two things - maybe huh I was
using Jordans earlier and I don't think
I had to I feel about this scope there
was any restrictions for me but when it
was a teenage one it should be just two
even a teammate's one yeah okay all
right poor Pathfinder yeah a little bit
a little bit dude he got nurse so hard I
was complaining about how like rate
didn't get nursed but you got here like
into the ground yeah
yeah I was like wow that was pretty
drastic it was like 15 seconds to 35
seconds yeah it's like see a purple
children I'm that is so cool I've only
got a standard shield actually you
deserve it oh so you can collect one
treasure chest per day I got mine
already
oh hey I got mine
nice we're fighting this there's one
heart heart rate right here and then
there's one fritters do here
hey there's like something down below
it's a three-way fight here bamboozling
wine as we weren't ready to the right
there's one up there you're firing at my
decoy cool right coming to you take we
get so Jericho that projects like one my
god oh my god
flip it down yeah yeah there's still
someone else there's blood here oh
you're still an open rate portal - I
don't know if that stays after I hope
low but low blows uh crusade she just
used it okay bamboozling I think they're
up top where we were yeah yeah up there
yeah they're firing at my decoy
different this is all different it's
blowin my mind why do I have a piano
actually don't like this new loot oh
yeah I liked it when it was all one list
oh there's a blue light magnet this box
alright oh bloody hell a light Magnum
right there fighting each other ok
bamboozling nice did I hit I tank
everybody yeah I went too far
oh ok ok I was like this is dangerous
oh ok we got someone here I'm moving up
to take I killed one big build one over
there I hit her for 140 over here it's
over anger she might be a low buzz
there's one left up here
my god I got it there's another one down
here though watch out she might be
flanking one of them must had a self
revive or something cuz they were all
down together I'm gonna send a bamboozle
down one just send it over the there we
go we can't send it as far Lutie so hard
for me right now
I hear her running i hear her running
right here see she's up there she's
coming up the ramp yep she ran past
reviving she's driving she was just in a
Hail Mary for sure if you get a thing
longbow you can use that skull piercer I
have Sentinel right now I don't even
want know why I have this so it's not so
bad okay I feel pretty good in like a
year at the moment send out a bamboo
tour just for fun mm-hmm
well what happened he vanished into the
truck that was weird friend circle oh
yeah are we far from the circle we're
like no we're not great a lot actually
well we're in a really great spot 10
years later I eluded you guys want to
move more what do you guys wanna do
we'll move more toward the coast or what
why don't you pick a spot I could use my
middle with the center drop have you
here
oh actually I'll take it from one of
these don't worry about it I got it
there's plenty in in these I just forgot
I had the bat here
I've look in a different tab for heavy
armor now that's why I wasn't used to it
my black market now - I should be just
use that so we didn't have to go through
each box my dad we're slow but oh I hear
fighting yeah I hear that - go okay go
over there yeah let's make our way open
or you go say hi
why aren't abs working in the lobby yeah
there was some weird stuff going on chat
weird stuff today but it might settle
itself out after a couple of seconds hey
you guys want me to send my decoy out
ahead of us oh it's out of the circle
huh yeah four squads
oh man 37 yeah we'll be able to get back
in see even in Apex they wanted to
terraform so we have a brand new area
yeah I made some custom pads what's the
cue art for this plant right here let me
know oh why not right now oh okay where
does that drop right here yeah I didn't
see the person foot I mean he's about to
Drago that's a respawn yeah yeah yeah
okay alright but they're not gonna have
like any 1k kill them good there
[Music]
right behind you take oh I tried to get
on top he's won he's down there's one
more somewhere things outside I think on
top on top yeah yep
dick if you keep him distracted
[Music]
someone's there's another spot there's
another spot if you saw top I think yo
gold shield
lopa behind us okay I picked it so I'm
running to you yeah
I practice shields but give yourself
talk oh no what was it front right here
yeah I said whatever we're killing this
group yeah we gots to who we are I gotta
heal up cracked
hello like which one is it he's here I
use this use this use this oh yeah her
weight is that bad oh but you can fly
away though you can fly though you can
fly off okay yeah where we going I guess
oh you guys are on top yeah we win good
shouldn't your spots should I use black
market right now and just use it okay
it's up to you there's a package next to
you Persia I mean they know we're gonna
be here anyway it's not like we're gonna
give anything away wait I don't know how
big the radiuses and I don't think that
was a good idea oh there's some stuff in
here if you guys want yes I'm gonna top
myself off all better be safe that's
awkward
nice I got mine for the day I did too
all right I'm controlling my decoy but
it's like way far away so hopefully I
don't mess with some people just keep
your ears out for us last two we can
chill until the last two we get the
rupee if you want to scum it of course I
mean we're in a good we're in a good
spot we could yeah just show
oh it puts your black market range on
the map that's cool yeah we do you guys
also see my decoy like on your hood at
all it just went away it lasts for a
minute now oh yeah yeah there I'm good
huh
hey hey what what footsteps footsteps on
this side
right now it's a like 195 200 it might
be in the building below us at like 210
unless I'm crazy and maybe I heard your
footsteps like you might or her aaj
maybe I don't was it outside of the
building though I don't know if my decoy
footsteps I wouldn't I was running
around okay we're okay
I don't know I don't know I can be next
if one of you gets me up the other
squads they're partying they just
spotted me right that shot shoot let me
get inside get me up come on a Phoenix
KITT
they're coming anything
yes I'm coming
right there on the roof I'm baiting you
hold on okay Chile Chile we are far from
the circle just FYI should we try to
bounce if it comes to that I'm just
saying can you watch this door to get
out yeah and I will use my Phoenix kit
he's got blue outside this window
they're fighting yet on the 38 seconds
they're fighting each other yeah one
just went into that building yeah can we
just go yeah yeah wait it won't let me
use it what the heck oh no oh because
they're coming up from where I died oh I
have no heal
- squad three that's good though that's
a good match oh did I throw the ring off
the map oh yeah you threw other ring off
the map I tried to climb over - and I
couldn't oh okay okay I thought that was
just like a wall and I thought I could
go over it but my fault
oh not so bad no it's so bad I'm gonna
I'm gonna stick with Mirage
yeah he's wild it's really fun yeah I
liked it when we went to like the last
ring I sent it off in one direction and
moved another so it was like assuming I
was tricking people like way far away
from us just like completely yeah it
took me a while to download the update
chat so you might just have to wait
honestly after I finished my update I
had to repair my game even after that
which was another like half an hour so
alright why wait for half of them locked
extra characters is like you can't just
drop spicy yeah I'm totally looking up
the patch notes because I want to see
what they changed Watson because there's
I have a daily to play as what's what's
here is Lola I don't know it's kind of
early to tell I feel like you know she
may be similar to Sombra but her ability
is not as good as some rooms where you
can just throw it I'm really glad I
added a new support character those
support is like just it's like it's a
really underrated yeah I actually love
these were leaping yeah it's that thing
I feel like you can kind of
like so if you're defensive character
everything you do is defense FEMA's
attack but I feel like for scout class
you have the most room experiment I felt
like everyone missed it yeah yeah I feel
like you can experiment the most for
scout class like I feel like that's
where they get kind of the craziest with
what you can do oh no right again next
are guys I got a passive why did I say a
passenger got a master mastiff sorry
right word for the game but wrong
situation oh man I'm just stocked up on
attachments and everything it's that uh
it's like the first place you raid
starter kit urger here you go there's a
what pages marked P 20 or at least okay
I also have a Mozambique game over and
call it a day
yeah whatever
and cross the open area like oh hello
yeah I didn't see the fit until I caught
up to you guys I kind of look that they
can make one map feel so new and every
season with all these changes alright I
like that it's like these specific
changes are like lore based to like the
rain it's like hi to Loba investigating
the facility or whatever in the trailer
no I didn't op anybody who may have been
you guys
I look for some more ham oh if you want
it definitely a bang yeah he's a batting
oh [ __ ] he has quick back we're going
spite oh I'm down I didn't even notice
she like jumped off trying to Hail Mary
me with that nest okay let's try it
maybe it's because we didn't wait until
everything loaded up in the top bar
first because I noticed I readied up
well the stuff in the top was so loading
you'll see what I'm talking about
are you talking about the late currency
yeah yeah no those are still bouncing
for me too okay so I'm oh wait to start
it until that loads they boast they've
been bouncing the whole time though so I
don't know that's really any different
or at least when the tabs come back
hopefully I don't know this is part of
the troubleshooting you guys gotta find
everything every way
we're beta testing yeah we're like
there's just issues going on right now I
think because the update is fresh so
that's probably why you haven't been
able to go into the store or anything
because as you can tell I can't go and
so start either I think I can go into
this yeah I think until until your like
currency sorts itself out I think it
like isn't gonna do anything else yeah I
mean other than you can cancel them like
ready open stuff mm-hm
we did manage to get Lobo of one Sally's
pretty good game yeah we got second I
was actually yeah I feel like if her
ability was like she threw it and it was
instant I wonder if that would be too
broken all right should I just try to
start it and I still wait to see if my
tabs come back no idea I mean you could
try and then at least if you try again
you'll know for sure that if the things
don't go away that uh we definitely
won't get the characters we want sure
yeah it's glitched out we're trying to
pick Lobo but it's just not letting us
close the game and open it again yeah
it's like all the characters and RMBS we
could try that I've seen some of my
friends like exiting out of the game and
stuff yeah alright so need you want to
drop spicy and then close or do you want
to close now and then come back
[ __ ] you we could just close out now and
try again
okay I'm gonna alter for ya yeah I'll do
the same alright let's restart this and
see what happens
release hell yeah seriously if you like
that I don't know though usually like I
would say most seasons leading up to
this they haven't had like this is the
first time I can remember them actually
having like a pretty big issue new to me
yeah but I also feel like they added a
bunch more stuff other than just like a
character in a map change no okay let's
try this again
oh it's yeah I mean like especially with
all the questing stuff
all I know is whatever is not working
today I'm sure it'll be fine later or
tomorrow are the little bit skin school
oh wow it dropped me back into our game
oh yeah there's reconnect yeah there's
really Rick that's a probably right
that's so fun maybe it considers an alt
F or like visto broken it doesn't know
that we purposefully left well alter
core was a part of the Reconnective all
options rips close robbing right in okay
still loading I'm dropping in a jiffy
hey I got a interesting the treasure
pack like mops out is a separate thing
it's not right it doesn't take up a
slide which is good
well me like it like dots spat out as a
separate item like it's not like sitting
in the chest yeah purser do you like
sniping I do sometimes I'm not very good
I have an Elster I uh I can all under
them definitely fighting yeah they go
off yeah we
[Music]
I'm just running headfirst into the mat
fine I just had to switch guns one
coming is that other side thing yeah oh
yeah it's in the hangar over here I see
smoke
got one
oh yeah it's all going down in here just
go on down there ah oh hey Tony I'm bad
that it mm I think there's one morning
oh no I'm wait to like every Brady it's
fine we got this
that's right really a girl it's cool I
just was missing everything like who
would [ __ ] everything I got nothing so I
could I'll take the armor off of someone
there's a blue crack I can give you bats
to extended light here purple here so
here's a I'm struggling with this new
inventory yes I don't need oh we gotta
go oh oh wow yes we do that's alright I
try to pour it all struggling with me
windows real hard
yeah yeah I don't like the way you've
quick swamp sit up now all right I'm
gonna abort you guys out of here okay
thank you guys I need all the time I can
get it they think mostly oh actually I
need a helmet there were a bunch
underneath I felt like this head is very
much for keyboard and mouse yeah
probably
are we all controller I'm glad we're all
controller in this PC world got three
kills though yeah that's good there's
heaviest I was don't Persian I have a
sticky W key I'm like oh like there's a
it's like runnin well we can just run
he's going to the jump Tower to he or
she
over there oh sure he's in the hill the
hill
apex classic you know top ten finish
number eight oh all right
oh you're not now hold on to my party
purchase though let me go to your party
then oops
there we go and my tabs are back so I
think my heart but if versions are then
at least with the Lobos stuff oh yeah
might works too I don't know yours maybe
it's just each different for each person
it's that East Coast internet man they
do have different servers that's for
sure
yeah I am pinging a New York server I
have an apex pack let's see what happens
maybe what if opening this pack suddenly
nope okay I was gonna get stuck trying
to open the pack all right you guys we
tried a ton of times to get Lobo it was
a little glitchy but we got it now we
got one game I know exactly the first
lova game and only a little oppa game we
played so far yeah we got a second so
let's get the Bellevue now all right at
least I got I got all the heroes here at
least exactly who is that Mirage all
right okay there's some of these heroes
I don't even own and I can select them
now well because I didn't buy crypto
Watson on this account yet but it didn't
mean I think I forgot about crypto for a
moment so when you guys were yelling
crypto I was picturing the destroy all
humans alien I was like what why are you
seeing him all right we got her success
okay this is the team we wanted let's
let's do it because I don't think any of
us play caustic I do but I don't have
them unlocked on PC because I'm a
screw-up ps4 player here Sam fix me all
right here we go a new area yeah
something I'm not very good at this
prairie-like going long distances
there's like a
okay there's like a bobbin beep thing
you can do to go a little farther but
I've never really been able to do right
so you do what sending my decoy off
landing here yeah yeah I saw the ping
sorry this okay and I don't see company
so I know all right when I land I just
like I picked I pick up everything
around me and then I start getting rid
of stuff I don't actually want to use oh
okay so I totally threw my bracelet over
into an abyss last a PTSD this is where
I died yeah oh okay so I'm gonna pick up
the longbow because skull piercer is
back this season you guys I've got a I
got it if someone finds the IVA I have a
double tap that's like my favorite so
let's see if I can land some longbow
shots today
oh we're hella far by the way just FYI
oh yeah right over there because the
dragons are going off no no there's no
one here it's all good well it doesn't
look we did see some purple thing I'm
like looking through the walls I think
is that a purple shield over there Oh
havoc with the Oh way no havoc
select-fire is not it's a battle thing
that's a I want the turbo with that
sorry for what
you could use a charged thing a new
black market right now oh yeah oh yeah
this would be good I that'd be a good
time for it there's a purple shield in
this box over here though this is kind
of cool like I'm waiting for you sorry
here Oh what's up top okay so another
addition you guys if you haven't seen it
already use charge towers and if
everyone is standing on the platform
they get their old instantly which is
crazy so here's the platform I'm a
curated ready guys oh it takes a little
while okay so I have mine as well oh
thank you and now let's access what do
we got around here you can good to go I
kind of like backpack yeah I need a
shield for sure oh boy it's a long list
I know it's everything in this area
because one this area was not looted yet
all right cool - yeah this is cool I
like that but it has to be pretty like
mild for you to sit down and like look
at that also oh yeah I'm gonna start
making my way we can use a tower
yeah and that I guess was just initial
that sour so if you see on the map you
guys this whole ring is where it picks
up all the loot it's not a bad radius
it's a cool area yeah
now we have to run I heard one of the
little cargo room or one of the you know
the robots you can punch yeah it's
abandoned over here oh I forgot I have a
backpack already got up shotgun bolt I'm
good light ammo actually whenever we
need to remember to use her ability also
that's oh I should have picked up my
staff huh well it's far away and no
one's going over there yeah that's gonna
be outside of the circle this is all
unloaded Wow drop light here okay thanks
you see our 301 okay did you are instead
of mag pay yeah I just did okay because
I was gonna say I just found this one
it's so quiet I'll take it yeah you can
take your pressure all right there we go
hey squats Wow my um my Lou thing is
back here anyone to use it again
yeah use it and then we can hit this
tower over here and you can get it
charged again yeah yes give us the loot
[Music]
oh yeah I'm in whenever
oh wait Tony Soto I'm coming all right
yeah we're good
I mines full anyway but you know
bamboozled nobody and then do it again
nice all right are we all or we are cool
all right I collapse that one so seven
squads and I've done well guys we're
cleaning up schanoes champions got eight
kills
oh yeah I'm also looking for the skull
here sir you see one oh there's a there
was a jump at there my bad we'll find
something good here
someone had to have been close six six
squads we finally made it into this room
pink gold in there oh I saw it yeah
that's cool no you can take it I don't
want it that's too much responsibility
the self of iris oh nice
hammer the hammer points now if you want
to sculpt fear sir is there a difference
between these blue creeps and the life
blankets okay all right what do we got
here it's so funny I list before I am
did the update the last time I open PC
Apex was literally Animal Crossing
release day
I'm Pei please don't feel sport not
doing dope fit I said though so I I
played a bunch I guess when a script
over the last character or came I don't
know whoever the character was before
Lobo I played a bunch and then hadn't
played since so like I had a big ol
update when I wound up last week and
it's you know warming up in anticipation
of loba
something purple in there looks like a
scope or something I see Everywhere's oh
I hear gunfire towards the west that's
the kill leader
oh yeah the the billboards he is on a
rampage though well okay what it only
takes one exactly he can't take us all
at once re oh yeah right
whoo there it is somewhere in this
direction
maybe octane area
I see death boxes I also see a Lobo
black market over there I'm top of the
pill oh I just saw somebody don't jump
down I wonder what they found
oh I'm not really getting close fight
yeah fight squat down trying to get to
you further okay I'm just you're not
being sneaky I think they are at top on
the hill okay how are we gonna do this
oh I just heard of arc start from below
from below assaulted jump scared me
we should uh yeah for a second
Air Force ups on me I'm you lava tractor
tractor
they've also got a mirage that was
terrifying I I would say contributed
nothing but I know they popped one of my
mirages I liked so I liked that they
changed that voice line because now one
who says it I know somebody is at least
relative oh okay there's two there's two
there in the window and they're all yeah
they pushed in on us oh good I should
have shot oh I forgot about the bracelet
I started tried to throw it through the
window and bounced all right that was my
fault
I can't you gotta remember yeah you're
right you're right chimes right I just
looked over at the chapter like he's
teleporter oh I forgot all right it's
all good oh my tabs are hearing out like
crazy I'm good now now I'm actually the
next okay yeah my currency is not loaded
yet so yeah yo what's good Ritchie are
you opening that apex pack seems to have
made it okay for me for some reason
interesting it was that like a debate
get my apex packs if you wanted to yeah
i fertile forgot about her ability that
would been perfect too because the
window is right there on the other side
where they were rushing from the left
it's all right work in progress
flank regardless the bang was and blood
Helen we're coming from behind yeah my
stuff still going crazy but oh oh - but
we should be okay cuz maybe hopefully
default if we uh you'll know right away
right cuz it won't show up
that's our picket like I said we're beta
test we're gonna narrow it down for
respawn ok I'm still good I'm still good
yeah I think but it's all good we're
still figuring this kick well I'm still
figuring this character out that was my
second game as loba but I like her black
market stuff I just feel like I I
personally wouldn't be able to use it
effectively if there was even one team
around me because I lose way too slow
but yeah oh snap you're a 90% you are
almost there almost gonna be in on some
season 5 actions
hopefully yours uh works well yeah I
know whoever whoever is whoever
commented that hi friends hi friends
sounds like he's gonna start rapping in
that Eminem song hi my name is bat fine
honey
where we going t going spicy this is
actually I like that I cannot send a
decoy while they're shooting that's fun
now the orange team looks like they
stopped okay yeah they they took a dive
okay I don't
oh no my looting this not optimal
so backpack in here if anybody found 2l
stars yeah just in the same box which is
interesting so I hope you like all stars
otherwise its box is useless to you
alright take that I'll take that I am
gonna take what I Sam there's someone
over there
they just won I only fell one but the
other ones up there up on top of the
hanger Oh what I need oh okay yeah about
that
yeah I had to back up I was getting
charged rifled
[Music]
come right at you Persia in this monkey
oh it's a low Buskett no oh he was right
there the whole time I didn't even know
he was being super sneaky it did seem
like it initially yeah match summary is
still not working but that's fine
oh it's working for me now but
interesting maybe at least as long as
one of us has it all good on their end
then we're then we're good to go Oh
screaming we Miam premium currency also
oh my gosh Mason I was having that
literal same problem the update would
stop and it would come back and it would
be like 10 gigs larger in size like
final size I was like wait what's going
on here booby feet I had a similar thing
but like the last time I updated it
would literally it would say like you
have 11 gigs downloaded and then it
would suddenly say I had less than that
downloaded which isn't how downloads it
was very confused yeah I gotta use a
bracelet right right I'm sorry I'm
getting used to character it also has
like a little bit of a startup so if I'm
like really in a battle I don't think
it's gonna be as smooth as like you know
tossing it and getting out but yeah I
still need to use it more a hundred
percent
I love that lifeline skin and her little
emo bad dog already oh we're so far from
the new area you know it was wandering
here we go we go some high tea or how
about that all right let's do it
now we seem ok to bring Loeb I'm gonna
use my yeah I'm definitely use my
bracelet in here me out sorry I was wait
until we were like right over there's
already two three teams Oh yep the
gang's all here
um where are we going oh god this on
here everyone yeah there's so there's
someone every match brothers one here
you guys
tell you got someone on your back they
were they were they broke away
[Music]
yeah they're just like to hear oh okay
that did not go in some Roger Norman
neither do I am really low but Louis
showed up behind Jewish accent new skin
- oh it killed me laughs well here she
go
she went down into the water she's on
the ramp now she's trying to kill me
sorry about her I'm good you can you
back up into this building yeah I'm
going around I was just kind of in her
line of sight really I took the long way
you know the scenic route I all I've got
some oats all right here we go
cool I got two mozambique's now it's
open I mean oh no oh yeah I'm so I'm
gonna get you because I can that cloak
now okay I use my bracelet right well
tell you that almost work okay um I did
hear a slit I did not use it in the best
of ways my matching means still not
loading but all right that was just
unfortunate situation we got this one
now I really thanks hope you guys are
having a good time
hope everyone that is still downloading
you know gets their downloads done
quickly and yeah honestly it might be
better that you guys are still
downloading so that by the time it's
done you won't run into any of these
glitchy issues or running into now right
now play who you want to play
okay already oh I love this skin oh no
it's not working
oh good whatever as long as it works for
you guys yeah maybe I should just not
select no I have my currency was fine
okay well I got her so we're good
Tony is playing Mirage but I do want to
try I don't remember if I have him
purchase on this account or not I said
check but um yeah maybe I'll get a game
of Mirage in there to just show off his
new buffs because he's actually really
good now it's really I really like this
new Mirage for sure that the cloaking on
revives is excellent that is such yeah
and when he's using the respawn beacon
he goes yeah yeah it's awesome
got quite a few squads dropping off
early here in the first half of our
flight who do we got
we might have one possible two possible
those other two might drop early I know
a lot of them are diving I'm gonna go
down just because I can't just because
it's fun to send a decoy in the air oh
yeah we got it one one yeah yeah just
one that's so bad okay they're going
there someone break a little farther
back oh let's use this old thing right
away I'm activating it instant
oh you're using your loot oh thank you
yeah oh yeah well I will will come over
there then this is really cool though
can only pick two things so so I guess
let's get uh some ammo i watch that that
mo just disappeared from the front that
was cool
ones down there and one the Cross Blue
Shield on lifeline I think oh I'm going
to go towards Tony okay so I can try to
get a better shields I'm just looting
the old-fashioned way mm-hmm you only
get two you know so it's like so I gotta
find some other stuff
um yeah I also don't know where all the
barrels are in this area yet so it's a
lot of turning a corner and finding
nothing that was super cool too I like I
said I watched top oh I forgot to take
my my totem down there up top they're
using items they can use it yeah thank
you I got interesting sniper right now
nice one they're going that way
shoot now party oh oh it's weekend
that's why they put a trap watch out
well I popped it for you I tried to
avoid it but I most definitely did not
we've got 30 seconds to be somewhere
else if we don't want to get cooked hmm
get cooked I love her voice Lang's
already know I'll land get cooked let's
go
all the boys work in this game is just
mmm so much personality and the voices
oh I have one actually I'll take that
yeah you know what I'm dropping this
Mastiff if anybody wants all so have
them but nobody wants an Evo shield I am
good whoa I cannot lose any more okay
it's bad it's bad
okay let me know if you spotted another
one yeah care package dropping right
next to us okay where's a little peep it
mm-hmm here action nine squads left
already service
oh yeah it's a it's been a little weird
in terms of start but it'll all we're
sort itself out in time you guys alright
let's see we got oh gold piece key who
would like that no hey you want this
shotty
alright I'm gonna take it imma take it
way I just dropped a ton of shotty ammo
I'm gonna take a little bit up and then
we out
oh wait I'm not gonna be able to use
this on this huh nope I forgot oh is it
right cuz it's got its own thing right
yeah it's fighting me out 25 shots in a
dream let's go
hashtag 25 shots a dream there's
something gold in here
there's oh that's right you can't use
the shot am oh never mind
yeah which can I to be a good thing or a
bad thing later
how do you guys feel about their change
on the was it the gold perk where it's
um you get more get more health back
right instead of getting faster healing
o with it with the gold armor yeah I
didn't actually realize that was a
change interesting yeah something
changed on the perk there's something
similar to that hmm I guess I don't have
feelings on that yet then realize that
it changed yeah I haven't had a chance
to find it or use it know Flatliner
Spitfire isn't that the question hmm I
prefer flatline unless you have purple
stock with that yeah I think I do too
also I have a fun skin for it so
seriously where are they yeah those
other guys just like ran we didn't
actually engage them over in that sure
yeah no wise though I love she's Tom
Brady just eats it this is so far um
alright we'll try that again in twenty
seconds open chests over here so I've
been tried actually holding the ability
down to see if it tells me the
trajectory yet so wait there's someone
here oh my goodness I was like that
those feet are two outs
your man I wish I had my bracelet now oh
I do act oh they don't have a thing that
was I got hit by that uh actually oh
crap
up here oh no wait
did you throw yours I'm so confused I
thought they threw theirs they did
through this yeah I think they bolted I
wish I would differentiate who's this
who's nice I guess everyone can see it
when you throw yeah but that's fine
thanks
yeah run
she's still in here she's chillin I got
time for this are they fighting someone
else no I think they're trying to
Thursday no no I accidentally fold up my
map I was like hey there's people on me
and then like you're like oh god yeah I
bet you really the Peacekeeper is not a
golden item for the care packages they
switched it out with the Mastiff just so
you guys know yeah my nails are a little
long right now and they keep hitting
buttons that I shouldn't be hitting but
it's fine it's fine
I'm on it's so weird to because usually
I play on ps4 with the ps4 controller
but when I play on PC I use the Xbox
controller
yeah Xbox is big all right so I used the
bracelet let's go we did it man you know
what it did keep you alive longer yeah
it's it it worked as an escape
oh my god wait what okay I was like calm
stay still glitched out in the girls
days like now that one was me it's all
good
voodoo man he finally got Lobo he had
zero kills and zero damage or anything
he was like the same thing alright we
want to go back to we could go to the
new area but oh yeah you can look at
Elvidge how our ap school town news
right now
goodbye school town market the classic
classic fun
oh there there's somebody here though
yeah yeah yeah I think one of them was a
shame I threw out a decoy I don't know I
have no weapons way you're all on me no
guns over here I might have to make a
run for it is there any additional guns
in that room here and I'm back somebody
I might have to run there's a okay guns
in there the Peacekeeper here massive
yeah master mmm I'm pushing Persia
alright I'm behind you so
got one tattoo I got a heal she's in
here
oh she bounced she bounced yeah she's
like leaving she's applying out yeah
move next day no I don't want to go
through here Oh yep can you can drop
your drone her I used it already she's
on the verge I don't know I don't know
where she's at
I'm gonna have to hide in here then
because I got like one health okay send
out a deacon I think on top I think
definitely a bunch of dead like people
oh right yeah she's on roof but I don't
have anything to fight this right now so
I care I'm just gonna be surviving I
hear one out here too oh yeah but I have
survived down here somewhere there's
also someone up here there's another
squad they had all the guns
see it takes a little Rotenberg squad
down squat down here I have to I have
nothing like I have no oh I'm down with
one HP or whatever you get when you're
revived I think it's just one all right
I was like men I cannot find anything my
memory is still not worth the boxes that
there was nothing good in the boxes in
that one room
I killed too I wasn't I wasn't around
cuz this team was like flanking me I
used my bracelet though I threw it
through the roof and like went through
the outside but yeah I didn't have
anything every time I hear like morph
like footsteps coming in I'm like oh my
god I can't stop cuz I'm like on
controller and looting as scary so I'm
like I do not want to be caught right
now trying to loot let's try this again
all right we can get more than a
Mozambique this wrong then we might have
a chance might have a chance
did they fix the bug so far it's been
working for us actually and so I think
so
or it's at least smoothing itself out
slowly but surely the champion has he
finally got a little bit too everybody
go straight down into the new area yeah
[Applause]
there's gotta be some your squads you
want to try to launch that charge for
etiquette Michael they're all going
where they're going
oh let's see oh yeah yes oh dang we all
have the same idea
yeah this is not good oh no bad drop oh
you'll feel spicy real fast yeah oh I
did it too soon okay no no oh yeah I'm
gonna die okay I did not get any
he's missing he's so bad if I had a gun
he would be dead he's missing and I'm
just crouching can't play I was having
an issue when I first downloaded the
update I tried to start it and it would
be the loading screen
but then it would like immediately just
shut out the whole game I had to go into
origin and do the repair which ended up
giving me another like some other sort
of I don't know if it was an update or
web but it was like a like 18 gig
download or something I had to do it was
weird ultimate bamboozle I like it there
they all go that's so cool I know is it
Freddy's me uh go no gun then oh yeah go
run faster I didn't realize I even had
it equipped oh it was Mozambique might
as well not be a gun in my ass right
pick me the nearest one oh well I see
one right oh yes or no that's not it the
one you're going to use better yeah cuz
it's fine looted yeah
all right this is actually was the plan
the whole time you guys we gotta have
Tony revive us in a safer location
yep and then we're good alright I feel
like we should just committed to uh to
landing on the charge pad yeah but it's
fine we gotta charge on this pier dactyl
we're gonna be invisible now coming out
from here right that's so great oh that
applies just what he does if someone was
in there
I was shooting at a leopard okay I
thought I saw someone shoot yeah there
is someone here
I saw someone shooting at your decoy oh
okay
man's here okay I'm coming there's
someone sniping across there's a wing
man right here perfect there's more
heavy you just teleported to the top
okay
now might not have been the wave but
it's really low but okay it almost
worked but they saw me throw it it would
be cool though is if light cuz when
she's throwing it and the bracelets
actually coming out you can't do
anything she's like summoning it still
so it's not like oh I'm gonna throw this
out here and then like run and then come
back and then go through it so it's not
like an instant thing yeah yeah yeah
wind up but is definitely good because
like if she wants to get like on top of
a building or something that'd probably
be pretty easy to do that but yeah I
haven't I don't know how loud it is for
the other team though like because I
haven't really run into a situation and
I was right next to her yet no it
glitched out again
[Music]
dang feels bad
hopefully we can at least get in one
more Lobo game yeah we'll just chop
spicy yeah it does take a long time but
I feel like it would probably be
overpowered if it was instant
we got a funny Oh G squad right now at
least oh yeah
nostalgia pack one year ago nostalgic
time heart hard commit the pad yeah yeah
yeah here we go ready yep
Oh everyone's here these are all people
who tried to pick someone else and
they're like drop on I'm going right for
the middle Tower yep
uh he picked up the blue shield I'm so
sad
she jumped off yellow yeah yeah backage
is on here Oh doc nice I'm doing my
thing do your thing
this is going all halter there's
definitely yeah over here
that building here's a purple shield in
there he's on the roof he's really low
roof yep I'm also really low
Oh No where you at pressure I'm under
you but I need to grab this shield real
quick just real quick oh you're good
okay you're alive yeah
tummy is done there's a rape coming yeah
I just I just you load into it yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna use my my portal to get
us out just kidding I hear somebody over
here yeah this guy is also chasing me
watch out for when this rate this
probably guys take this portal okay I'm
I'm trying to make my way to Tony real
quick there's a hurry I'm on the way
Tony I'm gonna check my turnip prices
why you guys you got another team over
there fighting do you have batteries
result I do I got some light ones oops
oh no I forgot how to drop thank you
how much time we have all we got to go
get oh yeah yeah yeah we out of here oh
I forgot this oh that's looted oh please
I would already be here they went up to
where we're at already now coming to you
45 seconds
rings far all right here everyone's like
where's lopa it's not our fault the
game's glitched
yeah I was all excited to get my
invisible respawn now but I'm not
mirages so it didn't happen all right
I have fun I'll take what you had just
so I have some tolerance anybody yeah we
got to go huh
yeah I'm sorry again like that way okay
loot that
that make our way up I'll take something
even though I don't think I'm gonna use
it
hey Lobo what's the loot look like oh
wait yeah that would be great oh but
here do you want it now you go ahead
kind of like whatever game sure ill I
almost want to just find a fight so you
can get Lobo yeah yeah the right way
this was supposed to be that one you
guys we got we got we did get that
second place yeah globally we did
something fun all right
I thought I heard somebody oh yes please
mm-hmm I have I have Eva I haven't been
fertile again okay
let's get us out of here we out where we
go right back
that's the question yeah I think it's
the treasure boxes are limited to one a
day right yeah yeah you can't pick that
more than one yep and then you need five
John Locke a hunt cool
I like the sights so if they're adding
into it I'm really interested in
checking out the PvE stuff when that
actually hits I'll take all that stuff
where is everybody
uh-oh there's something Senate like my
Caleb tried a gray one just yeah bear
backpack though Oh cold Spitfire don't
worry buddy
oh nice oh I should have let you open
that one says she could have got the
extra the extra goods what's that Oh as
lifeline yeah
so if lifeline opens a blue one there's
potentially better stuff in there extra
no I can still I can still open it Oh
sick
yeah right I'll be right up dear thank
you I feel like I have not played on
king's canyon and so long yeah I ended
up falling in love with world's edge
that was my problem yeah I'm interested
like you know obviously though I'm well
not obviously I assume they'll
eventually make a third map I'm curious
what that will be
Daniel third map yeah rotating through
even more yeah I'd be interesting all
right where it's you get fire
high squats yeah which we're doing okay
right Oh a lot of gunfire it's like 60
80 sir did you just 180 on the zipline
yes I didn't know you could do that yeah
you can turn around jump off and get
that guy oh that's what you'd okay I
didn't know if you like press some
button and then immediately just snap
back I'm gonna just finish
let's give us a second to catch up to
you there today I'm fine no not pushing
why signaling the game glitch here yeah
yeah it's
pretty significant update a lifelong
package to you I see that yeah oh we go
again right we're here we can
there's one inside looting still yep I
find crack going upstairs okay we get a
Lobo one in here to close it out they
fix it recite the game lines okay right
now my currency I don't know oh yeah my
tabs are back yeah I seem to be okay
so let me select her for good luck let's
open these apex packs I was gonna say
yeah opening any effective packs seemed
somehow he would fixed it for me oh I
got a common low the skin it's very over
watching with that color scheme do the
second one
oh did I just give them in gold okay I
got a finisher I got a race finisher
let's go
nice let's he clipped it alright let's
do this I have to do it
we got this umm she might be working now
I mean we were man we were able to get a
few games with her and then a few games
we weren't able to because of some weird
character selecting glitches but
hopefully it works this time we're gonna
check all the tabs are working yeah
that's that's usually what we were
experiencing if the tabs and your
currency and everything was loading you
would be able to select the character so
let's see if it works if not am
ragequitting
alright everyone's here so good here we
go yeah
he's uh let's do it guys go out strong
no pressure
yeah alright we're gonna touch my things
we're good
how soon do you think someone's gonna
make in a MV with lava using Shakira she
wolf yes that's literally what her name
is
[Music]
okay now we got the now we have the a
team so let's uh man they spawned us
fire away from the new area again I
think that rate that five thousand kills
oh I did see that yeah well let's let's
go get her
where are we going I don't know um I
guess let's go your choice we're going
there I guess this one if the dropship
is flying a certain direction and I'm
obviously once all right I'm gonna land
over here
yeah down to the band version here with
you with me
yeah he just ran through it's a
pathfinder don't ok I'm not here looking
for him guys Jukes me though where'd he
go yeah yeah he's over there I'm not
gonna chase him no because I have a
shield yet yeah I don't really have
anything to actually do there's a wing
man and a bunch of stuff in here ok yeah
he took the zipline across towards okay
so he just needed out yeah alright I
hear him sure that's not me outside oh
yeah I love top I think orient this
building
I'm moving to you guys now oh okay so if
I throw it okay I might have figured
something out we also have another squad
coming from behind okay but I have no
shield cells so oh just kidding
she's up here watch out behind she's
dropping down probably no she's not
she's good up there she stayed up
it's a reef and I think that's all
octane coming from a far
oh that was the best
oh that was so that was so cold I know
one more one more one that rave to walk
right back yeah that was actually great
that was pretty cool
if I didn't like miss every shot and
that would have been even better because
I wrote it down oh that was so cool then
I think though like obviously I think
Loeb is really cool but I think Mirage
is like the star of this update right
now yeah these changes are real cool
it's really good all right I thought
that area was gonna be all calm nope I
thought wrong
you should be good though guys if your
apex is not working try giving it a
restart or something because at least
for a PC it seems to be working right
now I love this costume now even though
it's not like one of her legendary ones
you feel it up going Brandon all right
you know what it's true it's happening
right now we're doing it right doesn't
play anybody but rave ever yeah but I'm
saying like you know like that's all the
place so they have mastered that
character and we're in line of the new
area this is feeling like it's it indeed
yes Braden dug inbound dove is on the
way let's go tossing out on my clips
remember eyes on the front one do top of
the building again yes good one right
next to us prepare to dive oh yeah let's
do it we're going to be but no one else
is going tops okay I'll hit something I
don't want that
nice nice nice okay yes be very I got an
Evo shields okay I don't I don't know if
my traces were the best but
so if I hit LT again oh yeah yeah I have
no ammo
okay those my I have a grenade tip it
around right there did they sit back
into they jump off they jumped off
facing um I'm out of ammo
all right we're clear I heard the sound
we're clear let me go back up and use
your thing again Persia did you already
get two things or no oh right that's
right it's after 2:00 hmm I heard this
out I'll have no weapon right armor
cracks yeah there's another one up here
it might be another yeah oh my gosh I
desperately need to find some ammo hurry
I'm sorry beep white armor cracked on
the roof actually whoa I'm gonna die Oh
Oh jump-scare oh my luck I'm sorry guys
I have to go fine stuff hey I'll come to
you when I get a chance
- cannon oh man okay I'm coming back
around I guess oh boy all these Cal
sticks I just need something that I need
something with oh Jesus oh my gosh yeah
I was like I have no I had no ammo
there's nothing anywhere all right you
guys want to try one more time or you
want
okay last last one dang every time I'm
just like running out of stuff so fast I
have like one clip that's the fire I
should have picked up the Spitfire and
more ammo but I picked up a body shell
it's like a drop a body ship the one I
had on up with us but I don't think that
worked out very well I do like that play
though if we can get that top area and
then use it like market right away
probably got our the two things you take
whatever has to be able yeah yeah it's
nice to be emerald poor like you should
know you should because she ran out of
ammo and I did 200 you're saying like I
gotcha good to know
for next time yeah I know Braden we need
to get in tub at least one I mean yeah I
got eight kills with her so far so it's
pretty good the game is still not
working for you men it's been working
out for us so far we're on PCs so I
think PC usually gets the stuff that's
uh you're supposed to be hot fixes yeah
say yeah let's get pop Jones welcome
back where we feeling um well we missed
the charge pad wherever at this plane
all right some water treatment some good
ol water treatment or we could have
taken the portal but no well yeah we're
so far away from everyone I want to say
what spot or what spots coming
what does one Spy is coming with us okay
that's alright too
maybe two spots
he's stopping right here good friends
oh no okay they still decide a mirage
Chris attachments as far as the eye can
see
oh my god it's spicy over here throwing
punches I'm being executed
we're not oh crap there's someone here
no oh god there's like five million
people here
dang should I have taken my chances with
the Mo's Andy thing cuz you not only hit
like two out of three of those snipers
ah you're good oh dang alright well
that's just how I be sometimes in the in
the mean sheets and I think Eric's mic
is muted again yeah oh my gosh alright
what one more the for real last one to
am hits but just yeah yeah all the
characters that are not like the
original characters this is a weird
glitch going around you guys dogging I
should up my field of view you know I
have been hearing about that but I
haven't messed with any of those
settings in I'm scared to break it to be
honest
cuz yeah
technology hates me and any time it can
go wrong it will so I try my best not to
touch it once it's working because my
orangie is bad you guys seen it first in
all right here we go PC gets all the
good stuff I mean it might just be
easier to get the stuff push through to
PC master hey guys that Wraith only had
27 hundred kills oh we're getting
somewhere
sorry there's gonna be mad spicy
yep they're not so crap oh yeah I'm
gonna yeah finish your Watson down
plenty more okay so they've got one more
somewhere Thanks so cheese oh there's
one more she jumped up yeah she dumped
uh I still don't have a gun I hear
someone coming up though
are you happy of everyone trying to get
a gun oh no okay okay all right
I'm just running for a completely
different building as soon as I get up
by the way oh my gosh yeah someone's
coming up you just dumped up oh man
they're both up here I want I use my
bracelet to get out play right here with
me another one just came up they're
fighting each other
I'm just jumped off I'm so far away I am
out of position do I have heels no but
it's fine I'm coming back I guess no
getting far away was the right move
that's what you should have done that's
what I tried to do and then race the zip
to right up into my face arch start
coming up oh no that's your very hair
never mind
whoa there's no heels over here I still
have no heels no should I wait it out
and try to revive you guys after yeah I
would then I could actually get my
invisible revive oh I hear I'm reviving
all right shoot I'm still sick if you're
gonna wait it out yeah without insight
yeah I'm like please don't look over
here no one's over here I was gonna stay
underneath I'm like if they drop down
and see me I'm even in a worse position
crap even a syringe would have been
great right there hmm
yeah for that area being new there's
like surprisingly like not awesome loot
there's like a lot of attachments and
stuff at least when I'm dropping there
like that's I'm up from the thought
there was like no it goes all right well
we actually have to go do real work
things now even though I wish I keep
playing it would be awesome but yeah
thank you guys so much for tuning in
and you know checking out some Lobo
there was definitely some glitches going
on and all that but it's all good I'm
sure they'll get it straightened down
these last few games we were able to
pick her we had a few games earlier
where we couldn't but it's all good
who do I me and I'm actually a
pathfinder man which is gonna change
because he got nerfed and she's around
but yeah thank you guys so much for
tuning in I'm gonna play more Loba try
to figure her out more get more used to
her I recommend you guys do too it's
pretty fun and thank you and if you want
to tune in to more of our live streams
well we stream whenever there is new and
upcoming releases and anytime something
exciting like this update is going on is
when we'll be live so make sure you tune
in stick around and check out the
YouTube channel while you're at it and
the website we've got content going up
all day every day so peace out thanks so
much and catch ya later
that's for sure I'm gonna hop off yeah
maybe the same